hello and welcome to this video playing
a down low with white let's see Queens
gambit a try for some different line now
here with e3 this time and see how I'm
faring this is a rare line but it's not
so bad oh that's an early commitment
however can I see the point but I can a
kadai I I should do this I sorry for the
stuttering but I think ash every should
I really had to do this otherwise um
that doesn't make any sense to quickly
open up this position
he takes it he doesn't um k g3 I guess
that tweenage Foy's bit too annoying
okay i can even if rising over here
sorry for my fading voice okay just just
play the normal didn't spend too much
time
they don't like you as my lacan
development just wants to check use
those squares hmm i don't know i don't
mind that so much to be honest maybe
this is the wrong assessment but i think
my king is kind of okay ani to where are
you going with this once to sacrifice a
pawn or maybe maybe maybe i can
sacrifice him but i don't see really how
my g5 no mc5 and i don't quite get it
well this is this one okay but i can't
eat with this just check on you five
hmm yeah what's the point checking on h5
but this is just it's just a check
mostly can also go back okay let's do
this first what is the point here Queen
h5 even g4 is a move to form an edgy for
is a very serious move actually I have
Quincy for as well cheeks I cannot take
it okay so G for Queen age too this is
just a check right
okay I mean okay Queen age for so only
move and then what do i do then this
move okay yeah okay that is that it's
definitely also move but I didn't see it
but I can take twice on you for all
right it should be six I can also check
on see flow of course but you have this
check on you two at the end this is the
problem
I can also check on c4 now if you get
one is not working I have to have to
probably just just take this stuff it's
got Bishop b6 now this is the thing and
Bishop d5 is is this the problem
sandal square yeah don't don't give me
that [ __ ] then 0 square i can go
this is this i cannot do this Wow
I don't see move I don't believe it am I
lost here that would be the weirdest
thing for a long time time morning yeah
sure ever seen a movie I see no more we
should give five I cannot play this inna
this was very stupid he can't so clever
should be five and i have no reply I
simply have no reply what did yoga are
nowhere have to resign you what the [ __ ]
away what else what is put a we had
stuff I mean this is a complete winner
of course for why'd he asks draw able to
miss click yeah so how do I win here
Quincy for wins and ticks and Quincy
four wins this yeah this losers I'm
really lost so what did i do here so
winning is less check andrew q1 and
that's it I don't understand that though
sorry the other 10 kg one
now you're lost here you don't need to
analyze this position now it just
completely lost but that whole setup is
just it's just just just awful for black
what what happened here there's
something something wrong here with the
position c-5m yeah the chip in age five
check wasn't wasn't good i mean this is
this is rather unclear i guess but um
that position is a total mess it's a
total mess and when he knows what's
going on check
yeah it's funny okay from that right I'm
a exchange down but the compensation is
very unclear yeah it was a very very
read position if I Foster was
interesting I cannot analyze when the
other guys moving some stuff all the
time it's simply impossible so okay
simply cannot do this because you have
no control who's moving when and then
it's like two people like yeah keep
putting stuff on the same bored at the
same time I would be interested in this
position after Knight takes in you went
Queen g5 and then 1c5 young so c5 is not
really liked by the engine wants to play
rogue f1
it's very murky the computer loves white
but this is no surprise it's still very
murky position I've got this pawn and
it's not clear what blacks compensation
is but c5 isn't Jack Reed this is as I
said should lose but this should be six
is interesting and then because now this
this is immediately clear that it's very
dangerous oh yes it's almost the game
and they have no move AB should be six
strong and then we get this weird
position that be like this this 92 it's
very weird yeah c5 wasn't good it gives
him gives him that square I was very
much tempted by the check on c4 that's
not so worried yet here I should just
wait now and it was very stupid uniform
check now you're black has simply no
idea it's nothing simply nothing going
on but that pieces is a goner and a
threatening neither seven so can I
gunite up seven is not the easy yeah
probably check Wow check that's a cool
move check checkmate I'd losers check
this is a draw check check funny so I
cannot just check them and before then
push it back up to three jen i can check
yeah it's still tricky but objectively
white white is winning them but he can
go we should be six and then things are
totally unclear yeah I'm very happy with
that one thanks for watching